nancial services committee voted today
along party lines to create a Consumer
Financial Protection Agency chairman
Barney Frank led a news conference
afterwards it's about a half hour
thank you all by n first needs to be
here please suppose with Travis to be
able to announce that were not announced
but to note the enactment while you i
would say the passing it's not like
somebody died to accept the fur intent
to celebrate the fact that the committee
passed i think one of the most important
consumer pieces of legislation I
remember back I guess during Jimmy
Carter there was an effort to do a
consumer agency and it died i'm joined
by two people elizabeth warren who has
been one of the key shapers of this idea
travis funke of the consumer federation
i am enormously indebted to both of them
for both the intellectual and political
work combined that we have had and it
was very clear this is not a bill that
any one of us would have written but
given the process and what we're up
against I think it is a very significant
advance and I will predict it will only
get better from our standpoint going
further frankly the committee process is
often the hardest to deal with so I'm
very pleased with the way it came out
there were a couple points where I think
we can improve it but I believe it is a
major breakthrough and I would note that
simply with the derivative spell for the
first time in our history we've
established the principle that we will
compel derivative trading on to an
exchange now we want to improve that one
and we now have a standalone consumer
protection agency that has very senior
in powers I've just note even in some of
the areas where we had to make some
compromises every bank in every credit
union America will be subject to the
rule making of this agency and any
complaint of a violation against any of
them will go for this agency and they
will decide that there will obviously
there's some compromising examination
but I do want to stress that even there
and another major piece of this that we
want to stress is there are a whole
range of activity now that is under no
federal regulation and in
cases no effective consumer regulation
at all payday lenders check cashers
remittances the sad fact is that the
lower your income in america the heart
the more you pay for financial
transactions we combined with some good
literacy provisions in here and this
regulation we think we can approve that
I mean how ask Elizabeth Warren to say a
few words Thank You chairman Frank um I
just want to say when I first came to
Washington with the idea of this agency
everyone told me the bank's always win
quit now because the bank's always win
they didn't win today chairman Frank has
done something that is historic here uh
we now have a bill moving out of
committee and onto the floor of the
house that establishes an agency that is
independent but has tools to begin to
fix a broken credit market and and that
is an occasion to stop and Cheer it's
not perfect there are some changes that
should be made and I'm trying to learn
the process as we go along I I hear that
this is not the final salvo but but i
really want to stop for a minute and say
how pleased I am I never thought I'd see
this day so I'm delighted Thank You
leavis and my colleague Dennis Moore who
has played a very important role Dennis
was a first-rate legislature and without
his cooperation and the respect our
colleagues out for him we would not be
as far along as we are today tense Thank
You mr. chairman and thank you professor
Warren I appreciate everybody being here
today we are in a troubled time and I
don't need to tell you this in our
nation's history in fact we haven't seen
anything like this since the early 30s
in our country and most people that you
talk to here or back home are not old
enough even if they were alive to
remember
what happened back I mean remember it
firsthand what happened we are going to
get through this and I really appreciate
the leadership of our Chairman I
appreciate the leadership people like
Professor Warren others because I think
we are doing taking some steps right now
that we need to as a nation to address
this situation head-on and not stand
back from it because if we don't take
positive steps now things could get
worse we've had some boats in the past
year and some of those votes were very
tough votes there's a lot of lack of
information lack of understanding i
think out in the nation about some of
those boats but i think some of the
votes the hard votes we took in fact
kept our economy afloat and it could
have gotten worse and there are a lot of
people still hurting out there and there
will be for some period of time as I was
hoping things would get better faster
than they have but the at least were on
the right course now I think there is a
mend it's taking longer than anybody
wishes but we're going in the right
direction right now is the nation and
finally Travis Plunkett mr. Plunkett on
behalf the consumer federation
understatement mentioning three areas
where we need a proven I agree in all
three areas and I I am comfortable be
able to make some progress but I'm also
pleased that the Lester's frankly as
short as it is I couldn't have been
confident a while ago that we would have
gotten as far along as we have and we
haven't stopped Travis bunker and the
Consumer Federation has been an
extraordinarily important part of this
effort because he's combined a
substantive knowledge and a set of
political skills that have been very
helpful Thank You mr. chairman very much
and and congressman more thank you for
the role you played take you all back to
July do you remember political
obituaries were being written for this
agency the large banks that helped bring
our economy to its knees were fighting
back against the creation of an
independent Consumer Financial
Protection Agency and through August we
heard and saw many stories
about how momentum was being lost I want
to come in chairman frank and
representative more for the
extraordinary work they have done to
bridge the gaps that the points of
dispute on this agency and bring us one
huge step forward we are on the brink of
a monumental achievement for consumers
for the first time at the federal level
a independent agency to protect
consumers in the financial markets to
help them with the loans that chairman
Frank mentioned payday loans overdraft
loans credit car loans to make sure that
abusive and deceptive practices are
driven out of the market but also to to
help the economy to make sure that we
never again go through this the same
situation where abusive lending is the
spark that ignites economic failure so
this is a huge achievement for consumers
we're looking forward to working with
the chairman on the floor to improve the
legislation and we are going to be
working very hard on the Senate side I
think chances are now quite good that
we're going to get this agency thank you
well now be glad to respond to question
we say Brad Miller would've been here
who's been a an early consumer advocate
working with the Center for Responsible
Lending does North Carolina but he's now
where no one wants to be in the ethics
committee but he's there as a member of
the committee not as a a subject but and
of course others work very hard on this
we'll take questions if there are any
mail house um that's still being to
subside with majestic forgive me I'm oh
yes professor Warren has to go super
vice seven hundred billion dollars so we
thank you for um she was really the
author more than anyone else of this
particular idea um the leadership is now
deciding let's review the bidding or the
fact that we ignore the bidding we pay
in August akin compensation bill we
passed the derivative on I Pelkey
chairman Peterson and by the way yet
those girls are very close on you know
who has to go on the exchange and the
end users there's very little difference
the biggest difference was a grant by
them of authority the CFTC two separate
elements which we didn't know if that's
not our jurisdiction but we will finish
this security protection piece on
Tuesday maybe wednesday of next week and
then the week after that we'll get to
the systemic resolution the democratic
leadership of the house is now I guess
deciding whether it should be separate
bills are one the Senate had earlier
told me senator dodd who's working very
hard by the way i hope people noted that
what ken feinberg has recently done with
regard to tarp recipients grew out of an
amendment sponsored by Senator Dodd he
ought to get credit because he was the
legislative authority for that but the
answer is it's a leadership decision as
to whether lure one of the time were
together but we've also been joined by
one of the other members who worked on
this was indispensable and who combines
a a knowledge of the substance and an
understanding the register processor and
legal skills and respective is college
so let me ask Mel watch this everywhere
hello all right I'd be happy to answer
any questions but uh I don't know that I
have a statement is largely along party
lines you discouraged a little bit that
there weren't more Republicans that
believed in this agency no um you come
to accept reality after a while Damien
being disappointed that the Republicans
don't support sensible regulation is
like being a big dinner and being
disappointing they gain weight I mean
that was a facts of life I am I regret
this by the way let's again review the
history on the compensation fell three
Republicans in the entire house voted
for that bill none on the committee on
the derivatives built one Republican on
the committee voted for it wallah Jones
and today none of them voted for it and
they voted consistently for amendments
that would have gotten it we ANOVA
public
advantage I'm the other and I'm very
proud that the Democrats pulled together
and there was give and take because
otherwise you don't get a bill and but I
I'm very pleased to have the testimony
of mr. pumpkin professor one that we
have a good bill so yeah I think it is a
an unfortunate sign of a failure
Republicans do to pay attention to
reality but i will say by the way this
is a very long markup we were actually
in session i checked for more than 16
hours actual time voting and debating
there were about 25 of all calls between
the two days the republicans got to
offer 29 amendments 5 which or 30 mm is
five six of which were accepted so we
try to work with a mic we can't make
them be any different may between the
bill is introduced and the draft that
came out in September which i believe is
still how the final bill changed the
agency structure more to give me the
director a lot of the power yeah how
concerned are you though if down the
road we don't have a president obama
who's really behind this agency they can
appoint a director who's not as
interested in consumer protections and
that we can have seen president would
then appoint people to the Commission
who wouldn't work well i think we want
effectiveness i'm not a great fan of the
commission and then you get into well
it's got to be three to two and who gets
represented I think we do that in part
with the two boys the Advisory boy the
oversight board which what does this
move to blood in the oversight board but
let's be very clear you can empower
regulators but if the boat is put into
office or if the Supreme Court should
put into office someone who is
ideologically opposed to regulation then
you can't save yourself I mean no
structure will overcome that ideological
resistance
well I think that needs to be some more
discussion about what the Barnett case
actually says because i think the
substantial agreement or appears to be
substantial agreement that we should be
going back to a barnett standard I'm
resistant and I think I've convinced
other members of the committee that we
should all be resistant to just saying
we adopt the Barnett standard without an
articulation of the words in the statute
we ought not be seating that authority
to the courts as opposed to adopting a
standard ourselves so there seems to be
some disagreement about what the Barnett
test case says because there's a lot of
what it would dicta yeah I've been away
from the practice of law 17 years now I
forgot forgot what we called it there's
a lot of dicta in the case yeah yeah so
there are a lot of different opinions
being expressed in the case by different
people but the opinion itself says I
think what what we have adopted as the
standard and I'm going to go back and
review that that case very carefully to
make sure that we've articulated it but
the concept is that I think the parties
have basically agreed that that's a
reasonable place to compromise get back
to the Barnett standard that was the
standard that was in place before the
OCC went overboard we think and
preempted virtually every state law so
that's one thing
this and some questions have been raised
about visitorial powers but that really
never was in what was delegated to the
small group of people who were who were
trying to work this out so if Bonnie
gives that authority I'll move over and
look some more at that the enforcement
the level of deference which is really a
bonnet issue also so I mean I think all
of this is constructive and at least it
certainly has been on our part some
people are raising the question whether
some people have suggested a standard
which they now beginning to second-guess
themselves and and say maybe we don't we
don't like that standard as much as we
thought we liked it so the only spot i
am struck by the form of your question
which is what more has to be done which
is also the name of the amendment but
the importance of what comes from watch
said is it the brunette standard works
very well we believe though that could
be one or two questions about it but the
burnet standard was a reality um in 2004
there was no chaos to be solved in fact
we asked the witness the Republicans had
to testify on this subject the gentleman
of the Heritage Foundation who was
actually quite an octree honest and
acknowledged to Brad Miller that the CRA
had a negligible if any effect on
causing the subprime crisis but I asked
him because he was for total preemption
leaving the controller's 2004 policy in
place what what were the problems before
that what chaos existed and he said Oh
none but since that time they've become
a lot of activists Attorney General's
running for the Senate in fact the
answer is before that we didn't
these be pumped the other question in
mail race difference now that we have
both bank regulator and consumer again
we also will be the question of
deference to whom and how that shared it
shouldn't just be in my judgment to the
bank regulator because we have the
consumer again so those are the
refinements we have to make yes being
amendment though um the the
congresswoman is said that she's gonna
continue working on this with you to
work this is what I think the general
framework has been accepted look the
bean amendment was offered in committee
not famous bean but by mr. Hensley get
lost heavily and including by the way
one of those who voted against it was
comes in Ron Paul because there are
still some Republicans who are reluctant
to do that mr. watt raised that issue
about what happened to the Republican
billing mistakes rights the one answer
he got was well they decided to
repudiate that because the Articles of
Confederation didn't work well as I
remember I was mr. Royce um but she will
be part of the working group on this but
the basic framework said to it is that a
member was often and defeated yes
offered on the floor I I don't think
she's playing it off and on the floor
she's pretty instead to work with us in
this area yeah scribe generally at the
end of this amendment process have you
just narrowed the scope or the focus or
we all know the scope or the focus we
have made a couple of specific
exceptions one over the objection of
most of us on the Democratic side and
the member was adopted to exempt auto
dealers we think that went too far and
we're going to try and cut that back now
the automatic knowledge and it went too
far in one piece he acknowledged that
there was an ambiguity and it may look
like the auto finance companies aren't
covered he suddenly agrees to that but
we will also be pushing there on the on
the seat the other major changes on the
smaller banks eighty percent of bank
assets will be fully subject to the CFP
a eighty percent of the bank assets are
in the banks that have assets over 10
billion for banks under 10 billion which
is a large number of the banks but only
twenty percent of the assets they are
fully covered by the rulemaking of the
CFP a
they are the place the CFPA will decide
individual complaints the compromise was
that the examination to see on an
ongoing basis how well they do will now
be a team based in the bank regulator
for the CFP member that was a compromise
that I thought was necessary to get the
bill out I would have preferred at the
original way I continuing said I don't
think being under the CFP a is going to
be a problem that's probably the major
area where we would many of us would
like to try and and and change that
other than that the bill is very very
much what we would like I believe yes
commenting on the administration's
announcement yesterday regarding
executive compensation okay question was
what did I think about the
administration to tell exact
conversation well conduct show there are
party differences when the bush
administration came to us and asked us
to do the tarp we raised those of us on
the financial subcommittee and some of
the other Democrats the notion of
compensation we put some language in
there but it's very similar to the
question i was just asked about what
happens if you get the bad regulator you
can empower an executive branch but you
can't enforce them you know long ago the
Supreme Court decided that you cannot
mandamus the executive in this country
mandamus meaning you cannot get an order
to make them do something in general in
terms of policy you can get an
injunction to stop them but you can't
get a Amen Amos so we were frustrated
that the bush administration did not do
that we were trying to get these
restrictions then again I want to stress
Senator Dodd was criticized I think
unfairly for the some of the language in
the stimulus bill it was that language
that gave Ken Feinberg the authority to
do what he's doing to cover these and I
think we got from Ken Feinberg Kentucky
while we were open to getting took some
time it was done carefully I would also
note that under this set of rules only
the bank's still having talk money are
covered but that's where the legislation
we passed in August comes in if any
financial institution in this country
where they got talk money or not
has a structure of compensation that
gives too much reward for risk-taking
and no penalty for bed rest taking we
think that's a stomach problem and our
bill that passed the house and I believe
will become all mandates that they deal
with that it also gives the shareholders
the right to vote on pay because part of
the palm here is some of these companies
60-plus percent was going to
compensation but I do think that Ken
Feinberg correctly use the authority
that he was given we try to get the
other Bush administration I congratulate
the Obama administration and I make one
prediction it may help us in one way I
think it's going to speed up top
repayment which I'm all for two of the
institution's citicorp and bank of
america have between them I think about
65 or 70 billion dollars in tarp funds
and if then all i could let them pay it
back let ya I thought the bill already
in some type of dealers and then
Campbell well we've all used ones
language myself included we don't exempt
or cover individuals we cover activities
so if an auto dealers sell you a car
that transaction isn't covered the price
of the car the warranty etc what we
cover are the direct financial things
now the reason all those are important
is that forget about this after your
house that's the biggest purchase most
people make so it's almost always
financed and it is the financing terms
that are covered again I'll give an
example we don't exempt any class of
people we cover only certain activities
with auto dealers I guess what the
language of the Campbell amendment could
be read to say that even if an auto
dealer is engaging in the kind of
financial activities that would
otherwise be covered because it's an
auto dealership its exempted that's what
we disagree with the the best example
that was the amendment offered by one of
my cards I think dr. price which said
that the CFP a would have no authority
over any health professional period to
find the up profession
those as medical doctors dentists
podiatrists speech therapists
veterinarians etc under his language
which was fortunately defeated if you
were a speech therapist and you decided
to set up a payday lending operation you
are paid egg onion which exempted
because you're professional so the best
answer is we covered some of the
activities of oral dealings and not
others and what mr. Campbell's amendment
did we think is to go beyond that and in
effect exempt auto dealers from rules
that would apply to other people that's
that's the difficulty we I guess with
one last one is house energy and
commerce expected to make many changes
to Billy pass today I don't think so
they had some structurally we consulted
with them and there was a general
consensus that it would be better to
move some of these powers to the FTC we
did want to make very clear that
anything that we did not cover into the
cfpa remains covered under for instance
the truth-in-lending act of other laws
so we'll be consulted with it i don't
expect major changes thank you all
because there are questions about
bankruptcy one thing within the
derivative bill is to segregate when you
put up capital to an exchange or a
clearinghouse they have to segregate it
to make sure you put up Chapel you don't
want it to be lost that involves
bankruptcy because you have to find ways
to you know keep that out of the hands
of creditors etc so too they get the
derivative bill and we talked to John
Kahn yesterday they'll also going to be
primarily involved in the question of
the resolution because i thought the
bankruptcy but i don't see any issues
today through do you consider this the
hardest the hardest one to get through
and you think the fed and regular
systemic risk will also be very I think
the resolution authority is one of a spa
be the hardest issues the second hardest
yeah well my putting it through this
different kinds of opposition but
finding the balance so you have
effective resolution sorry but without
money going to people who shouldn't get
it without warning people who screwed up
that's an intellectually difficult issue
that will make some progress or do you
think that this was a tougher bill to
get to it seems like you had to do a lot
of rain yes yeah because of the
legitimate concerns that the community
banks and credit you know and I think
we've achieved a good good results
material
would that go to the flesh separately
since it went public oh I'm sorry mr.
Castle one to the bell I apologize and
no Democrats no missing children in this
dominica public so we did get one
surprising you had they indicated they
would if an approach the goats catch a
report by like this funnier members of
the committee on the Democratic side
should fight me then I shouldn't be the
chin if the credit cards are gonna go to
the floor separately that's up to oh the
UH the one week mark upset doing that
Shep give me respond fed chairman's
seeming objections to the credit card
changes yeah although one of the things
he does say is that moving up will have
a lot of protections for the consumers
um I think they just gonna have to work
harder he says it's gonna take him
wallet his main objection is that they
ask people for they ask people for
comments and the comments aren't doin
remember 20th so I would just call my
shaking you get those comments in a
couple weeks early my guess is they all
can
it's beautiful
you